Even though I could not see
or hear anything,
I could sense the world
losing patience with me.
But still, I needed
to communicate.
So, did you guys want
to order?
Or do you need
some more time?
I tried everything I imagine
Helen must have tried --
clapping,
charades-style clues...
Tina: He has to pee.
...guttural moaning.
Surely,
one of these tools,
commonly used by the disabled,
would do the trick.
[ Moans ]
Lucille: Sounds like...
Forrest: But on a day when
I wanted to be taken
to see my ex-wife,
I was instead
robbed of my shoes.
[ Grunts ]
On a day when
I wanted a light snack,
I was instead
given a pen.
[ Grunting ]
On a day when I wanted to play
catch with my son, Eric,
like I used to, I was instead
brought to a drugs party.
And finally, on a day
when I wanted to be taken
for a stroll outside,
I was troublingly
brought to court,
where I was facing
trial for murder.
My caretakers had
failed me spectacularly.
This was the worst possible time
to be deaf, dumb, and blind.
[ Grunts ]
Okay, right.
Daisy: And what is your
relationship
with your ex-husband?
Forrest: I was unable to discuss
anything with my lawyer...
He's my ex-husband.
...who made
the questionable decision
to call my ex-wife
as a character witness.
During the time
of your marriage,
did he bring you flowers
or pay you compliments?
[ Forrest grunts ]
Um, yes, he did.
He did stuff like that?
Yes.
Oh, well he sounds
like a really nice guy,
doesn't he?
No further questions,
Your Honor!
Forrest: While everyone
tried to ignore
the presence
of a grunting visitor
from the 19th century,
Suzanne was asked if she thought
I would commit murder
for the show.
[ Grunts ]
No, I don't.
He is overly
committed to his work,
but he's not
so committed
that he would actually
kill somebody.
[ Forrest claps ]
Oh, my God.
And then, unbeknownst to me,
my lawyer made an even
more perplexing decision.
The defense would like
to call Forrest MacNeil.
This way, ma'am.
There we go.
We had always planned
for Forrest MacNeil to testify.
Down. Down!
Daisy: Down!
My attorney saw no reason
to change course,
despite the fact
that Forrest MacNeil
was now Helen Keller.
Thank you for coming
to testify today, Mr. MacNeil.
I'm gonna cut
right to the chase.
There is much Forrest MacNeil
could have said
in his own defense.
Is it true that
that guy, Ray,
attacked you first?
Indeed it was true.
Mr. MacNeil? Forrest?
Ray, the man who was killed,
was a violent sociopath.
Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh, god.
Can I get out of here?
Man: Oh, God!
A man who would surely have been
killed somebody someday.
You did this in self-defense.
Is that true, Forrest?
Say, "Yes."
Just say, "Yes."
The answer was yes.
I had no doubt
Ray was beating me to death.
You did this in self-defense.
Is that true?
All you have to do
is say, "Yes."
Say, "Yes."
[ Grunts ]
But Helen could not answer,
even if she had known
she was testifying
to save my life.
Okay, Forrest.
Come here.
If only my attorney
had tried harder
to remove my helmet,
or had not called me
to stand at all.
Oh! Oh, my God.
Bailiff: Ma'am,
sit in your seat,
or I will handcuff you
to this chair.
Yeah. I think we got to
go back to the seats.
Forrest: Being in constant need
of assistance made it clear
that in life...
Be careful.
All right.
That is good enough for me.
...we are surrounded by people
who do not fully apply
themselves to their duties.
As a result, I was not able
to exonerate myself.
And "Review," once again,
left my fate
in the hands of fate.
Living as Helen Keller
was an isolating experience
that required trust,
perseverance,
and a high tolerance
for minor abrasions.
She was a remarkable woman and,
for a little while, so was I.
And I give being
Helen Keller five stars.